alors avant de partir en vacances même
si pas vraiment nos vacances je me suis
dit qu'on allait faire un petit retour
aux sources avec un tuto pour final cut
et un tuto méchamment cool
mes jambes méchamment et salut à tous
les amis c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique moi encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour la dernière vidéo de
cette saison explique mois encore avant
de laisser tout le monde se reposer un
petit peu prendre des vacances et avant
de démarrer cette vidéo je vous
recommande vivement de rester jusqu'à la
fin parce que je vais vous parler d'un
projet qui est hyper important pour moi
que j'ai commencé il ya un petit moment
déjà et qui va voir le jour très
prochainement et qui je pense va
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup vous
intéresser et puis aussi on se tient au
courant assure un stade il y aura des
petites story des machins y en a déjà
pas mal
oak suivez moi sur un style ya toujours
des choses sympas à regarder alors comme
vous avez pu le voir dans l'intro le
tuto d'aujourd'hui va se porter sur cet
effet d'écriture néons qu'on peut voir
pas mal sur un stage sur les différents
réseaux sociaux
d'ailleurs l'ami a redit ce qu'avait
fait une vidéo là dessus mais sur
première ici on va utiliser final cut
parce que oui première gers étaient
faits en natif final cut il va nous
falloir un plugin et avant de me pourrir
dans les commentaires oui c'est un
plugin payant et coûte 30 bal et je ne
suis pas payé pour vous le dire je sais
pas une vidéos sponsorisées je toucherai
rien si vous achetez le plugin en
question je le trouve juste hyper cool
mais quand on voit le prix de final cut
par rapport à l'abonnement de premières
balles je me dis que de temps en temps
pour investir dans des petits plugin
quand ils sont sympas et ben voila moi
je me présente celui là aujourd'hui
parce que je les trouvais plutôt cool je
les utilise et 2,3 fois des petits trucs
dans certaines vidéos d'avant et puis je
m'en suis servi pour des clients aussi
donc vaut la parenthèse plugin payant
fermé on parle plus voilà moi je pense
que les trimbale ce plugin
il est alors première chose à faire
c'est de télécharger d'acheter le plugin
dans le lien qui se situe dans la
description ensuite en l'installant rien
de compliqué et direction final cut là
ici j'ai fait glisser dans ma timeline
un plan sur lequel je pense que cet
effet peut être sympa je vais ensuite
aller cliquer sur ce petit bouton en
haut où il y a les titres et les
générateurs je vais aller chercher
pixels film néons
et je vois j'ai plusieurs quelques
défait à ma disposition mon plan était
en full hd en 1080p je vais donc
sélectionné le calque qui va en fonction
mais si vous faites de la 4k avoir plus
ou moins mais il ya des calques pour
toutes les résolutions
je vais ensuite faire un glisser mon
calme juste au dessus du rush que je
veux traiter et je vais l'ajuster pour
qu'ils fassent exactement la taille de
ce plan en question
à partir de ce moment là je leur tous
les paramètres qui vont apparaître dans
l'inspecteur sur la droite et on va
pouvoir tout customiser à pouvoir gérer
la taille du trait du tracé d'ailleurs
on peut supprimer le tracé sur une image
si on veut recommencer aussi nous
convient pas en cliquant ici
on va pouvoir également modifier la
couleur ainsi que l'intensité du néon de
la brillance de la puissance on va dire
de de l'éclairage entre guillemets qui
est produit par ce trait une fois que
j'ai choisis parmi tous ces paramètres
celui qui me plaisait pas je vais plus
avoir qu'à dessiner image par image
l'animation que je veux créer un petit
peu comme un dessin animé au final
davantage c'est que si on se sert à la
base de plantes qu'on a directement pour
un entouré des choses ou pour surligner
des silhouettes
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir des talents de
particuliers de dessin il suffit de
suivre là en l'occurrence je le fais
avec ma souris on peut le faire aussi
avec une patte graphique je pense que ça
serait beaucoup plus efficace et ensuite
à l'aide de la flèche de droite sur le
clavier on va pouvoir avancer image par
image et il va falloir dessinée image
par image
notre petite animation si jamais vous
vous trompez ou que vous vous louper sur
votre dessin il n'y a pas de souci on
peut effacer des parties du dessin en
gardant à appuyer la touche commandes et
en cliquant tout simplement à l'endroit
qu'on veut effacer autre chose si on
veut rajouter une couleur on va tout
simplement aller chercher un nouveau
calque qu'on va faire glisser là aussi
par dessus le premier en modifier la
couleur dans les réglages et c'est parti
on fait une deuxième couleur un deuxième
élément faut savoir aussi que sur un
calque que vous pouvez a posteriori
modifier des éléments c'est à dire que
si au départ on a fait du verre
et que finalement on se rend compte que
c'était plus sympa avec du bleu il
suffit d'aller dans l'inspecteur et de
sélectionner la couleur et tout ce que
vous avez dessiné changera de couleur
instantanément une petite astuce que
j'ai utilisée aussi au début de cette
vidéo c'est si par exemple on va
dessiner un objet qui n'est pas présent
dans le film on n'a pas les contours
pour dessiner pas tout simplement on
peut importer une image dans la timeline
la baisser un petit peu en opacité
éventuellement et faire le contour image
par image de la même manière que ce
qu'on vient de faire là tout de suite et
c'est toujours aussi simple il suffit de
passer les contours et de pas dépasser
les coloriages c'est nous qui ne dépasse
pas tu fais ton très la cause et voilà
pour ce tuto surtout surtout surtout la
dernière chose qu'ils font que je vous
dise
absolument il ya un truc complètement
fou sur ce plugin c'est qu'il ya pas
d'auto save la sauvegarde ne seront pas
automatiquement donc si vous passez une
heure à dessiner que vous fermez final
cut sans avoir sauvegardé ses morts dont
il ya un petit bouton save canevas vous
n'oubliez pas de cliquer dessus avant de
terminer votre truc parce que sinon
c'est foutu
voilà ce que je comprends pas encore
qu'aujourd'hui en 2019
tous les logiciels plugin n'est pas une
auto save ça a l'air très compliqué à
faire mais bon voilà vous le savez
surtout penser à sauver a enregistré à
la fin
et voilà on arrivait à la fin de ce tuto
maintenant à parler vous et moi de
quelque chose de très important je suis
en train de créer une formation pour
final cut une formation en ligne une
formation pour bien débuter sur final
cut avec énormément de contenu dedans
avec vraiment tout ce qu'il vous faut
pour ne rien louper dès le départ et
puis les petites astuces que moi je mets
en oeuvre au quotidien puisque je suis
sûr faniel que tous les jours cette
formation elle sera payante
elle sera pas cher et sera accessible
compte tenu de la quantité
d'informations qui aura dedans la
quantité de ressources qui aura dedans
je me suis servi vraiment de mon
background de
prof pour pour la construire pour avoir
un truc hyper pédagogique hyper simple
hyper facile à mettre en oeuvre et
j'espère que vraiment ça vous plaira
c'est enfin fois que je fais un truc
vraiment payant pour le coup mais vu le
temps que ça m'a déjà demandé que ça va
encore me demander
c'était compliqué pour moi de le faire
gratuitement donc bien sûr il y aura
toujours les plus tôt sur la chaîne
youtube et tout ça mais là on est
vraiment sur un cours sur un une
formation qui va vous permettre vraiment
vous de lancer dans final cut
sereinement et puis même si vous êtes
déjà lancé d'avoir peut-être quelques
quelques bases qu'on peut louper ici et
là quand on est otto dix donc soyez
patients techniquement ça devrait sortir
à la rentrée au mois de septembre et et
puis j'espère que vraiment ça vous
plaira parce que j'y mets beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie on arrive donc à la
fin de cette vidéo les amis je vous
remercie encore une fois d'être de plus
en plus nombreux cette saison elle a été
ou sera passé les trente mille abonnés
et là on va arriver à 35000 c'est c'est
juste un truc de malade il ya des vidéos
qui ont dépassé les 88 wulf
c'est trop cool et puis vous lire dans
les commentaires régulièrement c'est ça
fait hyper plaisir ça fait vraiment
vraiment chaud au coeur tout ça on va
continuer et on va continuer ça encore
longtemps
j'espère voilà malgré la quantité de
taff que j'ai il vaut vidéo je vous
oublie pas et bien sûr si cette vidéo
vous un plus on n'oublie pas le
traditionnel coup deux blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe en dessous
de cette vidéo on partage la vidéo on
s'abonne si c'est pas déjà fait et puis
comme d'habitude les amis surtout
surtout surtout même pendant était
restée curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo et n'achetez pas
n'importe quoi en formation d'ici là
vérifiez bien qui vous proposer les
formations
gardez vos sous pour quelque chose qui
marche bien petit conseil
merci les amis à très bientôt